when captain moore decided to launch a
national campaign
in his own back garden raising more
money and achieving more in his
100th year than perhaps any centenarian
in our history
he knew instinctively which organization
he wanted to thank
and support it was at is
the nhs and he was right because
there are many people and groups
responsible for the uk's
vaccination program and we owe our
thanks to our brilliant scientists
to kate bingham and the vaccine task
force which has
procured over 400 million doses seven
different types of
vaccine manufacturers the delivery
drivers the pharmacists
the military medics countless volunteers
but to get this life-saving medicine
into the arms of the nation at
the kind of speed that we're seeing
we're relying on the doctors and the
nurses
and all the staff of our nhs
and it's thanks to their effort the most
colossal
in the history of our national health
service that we have today
passed the milestone of 10 million
vaccinations in
the united kingdom including almost 90
percent of those aged
75 and over in england and every
eligible person
in a care home and with every jab and
every day
we have more evidence about the
effectiveness of these vaccines
new research from oxford university
suggests the protection provided
by the first dose of the oxford
astrozenica vaccine
kicks in after three weeks and lasts
right the way through
to the booster at three months and
research
also shows that the oxford astrazeneca
vaccine
seems likely to reduce transmission
to others and even if these vaccines
cannot make us
invulnerable and no vaccine has ever
given
100 protection to everybody
the evidence increasingly shows that our
vaccines achieve this
crucial objective to reduce death
and serious illness from those major
strains of covid that have been subject
to research and in the days
leading up to our review point in the
week of the 15th of february
we will be accumulating even more data
helped by
nhs test and trace so that we can begin
to chart
away ahead starting if the date allows
with the reopening of schools on march
the 8th
and i'll be sitting out as much as we
can about that
roadmap forward on february the 22nd
and though today there are some signs of
hope
uh the numbers of covered patients in
hospital are beginning
to fall for the first time since the
onset of this
new wave the level of infection
is still alarmingly high and
i'm sorry to say that we've lost another
1
322 lives in the last 24 hours
alone and our hearts again go out to
every family
that grieves and the wards of our
nhs are under huge pressure with more
than 32 000
cobied patients still in hospital
and so tonight let's clap together
for captain tom at 6 p.m
and let's clap for the spirit of
optimism that he stood for
but let's also clap for all those he
campaigned for
our brilliant nhs staff and care workers
and let's
do everything we can to carry on
supporting them
because if we stay at home protect our
nhs
and save lives then in the words of
captain tom
tomorrow will be a good day